das garantie 7 garantiert ist sie sagt
wenn es kalender richtig geil ich
brauchen kurze moment um diesen
augenblick wirklich tief zu
verinnerlichen
länder videos meine freunde hier habt
mir wirklich viele viele nachrichten
geschrieben und ich freue mich natürlich
darüber viele leute haben schon
adventskalender ausgepackt ich bin so
gesehen spät dran die tak aber ihr wisst
nur ich bin das original so wie dieser
originale topmodels kalender von 6
was soll ich noch dazu sagen ich habe
überlegt wie ich in diese staffel 1
komme ob es irgendein großes feuerwerk
geben soll
aber am ende des tages hatte ich einfach
nur adventskalender aus und ihr habt ein
ganz komischen kind denn ihr liebt es
ganz besonders da es nicht um mich
sondern um diesen inhalt geht machen wir
jetzt das garantie siegel auf also wenn
ihr mich am instagram schon länger
verfolgen wisst ihr ich hab so ein
komisches ding mit james ex topmodel ich
liebe es aus irgendeinem grund und wir
haben einfach ein großes problem das ist
ganz schön aus der zeit geraten dieses
format also jetzt ist es eher so eine
reality show als wirklich einem model
suchen show und heiligtümer zurecht in
letzter zeit sehr viel kritik dafür
bekommt packten den trotzdem aus ich
möchte wissen was da drinnen und man
muss wirklich sagen dieser
adventskalender wurde so früh geliefert
und so früh angeboten ich habe das
gefühl der war schon im märz quasi zu
kaufen so und es ist ein james ex
topmodel kalender aber mit der
schmuckmarke six ich habe sehr wenig weg
deswegen hoffe ich dass ein paar schöne
teile dabei sind der preis liegt bei 69
euro 99 70 euro ich würde jetzt gar
nicht wenn der router schmuck drin ist
dann ist der gerechtfertigt wenn da
jetzt nur pins oder so dann sind dann
halt nicht freudig über 24 top aktuell
lassen stars gewinne ein professionelles
fotoshooting und fühle dich selbst wie
ein model
warenwert ist 135 euro man spart
natürlich wie bei den weißen etwas meine
damen und herren ich begrüße sie zum
diesjährigen adventskalender aus
wahnsinn und wir beginnen jetzt mit
türchen nummer eins finden mir gleich
hier
[Musik]
ja es ist eine schöne spanne auf jeden
fall
die hübsche spaß und hält jetzt nur
einen noch meistens dann zwei türchen
nummer
zwei das ist top aktueller schmuck leute
also wenn das so weitergeht sich an
weihnachten aus wie ein geschmückter
tannenbaum
die sind ja richtig schön
top-aktuell aus
jetzt weiß man ja gar nicht ob das
irgendwie aus mittel ist ob das
überzogen ist so ich denke mal alle
ohrringe sind bei sixx gleich so vom
material her ja uns mitteilt hat das
problem es wird jetzt spannend wenn ich
mit ohrring reinstecken
regeln aber die lasse ich noch mal weil
ich will ja auch was verlosen wenn ich
mir jetzt alles ins ohr stecken
ohnehin meinen dann kann ich ihn los das
ist einfach die schönste zeit im jahr
natürlich die nummer drei ich freu mich
hätten kann ich ja anprobieren aber
selber ist nicht so meins wirklich was
die silberketten
6 es ist jetzt hier nicht aber so wie
das hier aussieht kann ich mir
vorstellen das ist ganz nett ist sehr
gut aber manche stehen ja auch darauf
nummer vier
ich finde die präsentation ja wunderbar
mit diesem kleinen störche man kann den
wieder verwenden also dann im nächsten
jahr mit kleinen bonbons beide das
nichts anderes ein aber man hat das dann
gleich so auf dem präsentierteller
es ist alles wie so eine kleine
schmuckdosen man könnte sich diese
märchen mit so einer klammer halt
aufbrechen und dann wieder zu machen
oder man natürlich kette und kann das
dann so durchstecken dann ist es halt
ein anhänger ist aber auch sehr kleiner
137 euro
ich war mir ist es ein bisschen
ich habe die zwei übersprungen auch so
ein bisschen ja okay ich habe den mann
zwei übersprungen das hängt ja schon gut
an
winterliche motive wenn hier muss ja
sagen es hat ja nichts eigentlich so
richtig mit germany's next topmodel zu
tun haben einfach nur ihr logo drauf
geklatscht und die eine kandidatin dafür
werben lassen aber ich mag es dass so
ein bisschen thematisch zu weihnachten
auch ist man möchte ja auch zur
weihnachts- und winterzeit so ein
bisschen was fragen sie den es hier ich
werde die aber auch nicht anprobieren
weil hallo sung soo das war jetzt
nochmal 2 jetzt kommt nummer 6 und sie
haben ein wunderbares spiel gemacht weil
das sie auch ihre marke ist sixx also
ist die nummer 6 einfach nur ihr logo
klasse
das cool aus ihr leben ein bisschen
abwechseln ja ich würde jetzt schon mal
sagen dass dieser kalender höher heute
ist sie nicht so viel schmuck haben und
die das so ein bisschen aufstocken
möchten ich finde es sehr schön vor
allem das yin und yang zeichen hast zwar
überhaupt nicht zu meiner handy hülle
falls ihr gute handy hüllen kentner die
ihr wirklich empfehlen können schreibt
sie gerne mal die kommentare weil ich
mit dem apple handy hüllen überhaupt
nicht zufrieden bin sorry apple sein
sonst ganz toll aber löst sich richtig
auf die blockte ab okay okay
obwohl so weihnachtliches motiv ja auch
gut gewesen und es ist ein bisschen kurz
hier also ich hatte schon mal so ein
ding dran und das war dann halt bis oben
mit diesen perlen besetzt türchen nummer
7 es ist schon mein die probieren ja wie
ist die qualität also die qualität der
ohrringe ist okay ich glaube das was man
so davon erwartet dass jetzt nichts
besonders hochwertig aber auch nicht
irgendwie schrott ich also dass ich das
gefühl dass man spotten wir gucken uns
jetzt einfach mal an wie in den nächsten
minuten meine ohren richtig schön rot
werden ich habe sogar pickel prüfung
mitteile computer türchen nummer acht
die finde ich auch toll
sieht nicht billig aus aber ja also es
tut was soll denn das
gehirn auch super nummer 9 muss jetzt
aber was
ich habe nicht gesagt dieses videos
nicht gesponsert und bis jetzt dachte
tier ist sei gesponsert leute falls ich
euch jetzt in die irre geführt habe und
es mir leid dieses videos nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle diese dies
nicht
geschieht dann in den kommentaren wieder
als will sie so cool die früher sorry
ich werde älter ich werde vergesslich
jetzt gucken wir uns die schönste zahl
der wälder nummer 9 ich muss ein
bisschen wieder reinkommen wir müssen
auch zeit geben
ein armband hier sind schön ist also
wird sagte hierzu diesen arbeit dahinter
natürlich auch ein bärchen ich was ich
einmal angucken ich glaube es könnte
steht ihr auf diesen appellen alles ist
ja vorher trennen die dass das so nach
selbst gebastelten spülkasten aussieht
aber irgendwann hat man sich dann auch
satt gesehen jetzt passt jetzt halt
nicht so zu meinen bin hat er seine
goldman
er selber dran machen wenn man sich halt
mit 30 noch mal fühlen möchte wie 12 0
und ich habe nicht mal bei der 6 an
nikolaus gedacht
wirklich nicht mehr das gleiche
okay das nächste wird besser versprochen
gibt mir noch eine chance das hier ist
ein bisschen also ich sehe das ist
ohrringe
das ist hier wieder so ein typ wie crm
ne
also vorne haben wir hier diesen
fantastischen stern dann ist aber von
hinten dieser zumach teil der hat es
dann drei dann kommen so von hinter dem
ohr kommt so ein zeug raus das wollen
wir doch alle irgendwie zeug aus unserem
ort und fragt mich wie lange so six
schmuck hält falls sie mal damit
erfahrung hat schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare
wir haben hier einen ring und er passt
schon so zu den anderen motiven also zu
malen mohring passte auf jeden fall mit
dem gehen und handzeichen farblich passt
da aber auch sumann hängen möchte ich
bitte an ich weiß jetzt schon nicht mehr
lieben aber ich werde ihn lieben ist es
nicht toll wenn man hier mit den perlen
wozu man
kommt
daher gold mehr mein ding und solche
habe ich die ganze zeit schon gesucht
bzw
mal gucken wie sie mir gut tun werden
aber sind auf jeden fall der look den
ich haben möchte also die sind echt toll
ist aber auch komplett gerade mode die
so in echt gold früher hätte ich die
aber angeschaut hätte gedacht das sind
so mohring muss meine trends verändern
sich hat dass sie dass das sieht
wirklich aus ich diese sterne kann sie
nicht gut das ist nicht schön aus der
könnte mir ja auch jemand erzählen das
ist die fersen collection und ich würd
sagen jahre steht das sieht aus wie
frozen collection ich weiß es ist so es
sie dann doch billiger aus als der rest
von dem schmuck
beißen die geschichte hier mal ein
bisschen arg frage ist ob ich also etwas
handelt und
das ist ja auch das problem bei solchen
adventskalendern das ist zwar hübsch
aber einige wenn das anschauen sagen wow
oder andere würden das hat niemals im
leben tragen 15 etwas großes wir lieben
große sache ist natürlich wieder eine
haarspange in lila die gleiche die ich
schon immer hat die grüne besser da sich
blonde haare zu 16 aber grün war ja doch
schon
gründe ist ja auch zur weihnachtszeit
gehören wie man nach zwar am grün und
rot und das sieht aus wie weihnachten
ich glaube doch ich glaube die behalte
ich manchmal sitzen und die gebrauchen
können
ein wort eine bordkarte santa baby war
da haben wir wieder den weihnachts
bezogen hat dafür das ist ja eigentlich
weihnachten ist man schon mehr
weihnachten machen aber wie viel
weihnachten braucht mal am ende des
tages and it baby das ist eine kette für
mich wort ketten sind wieder
da kommt sie schon eine richtige
weihnachtsstimmung mit mir
war dass ich meine chance wenn ihr jetzt
mir kommen machen fehler und ich wurde
dazu gezwungen wartet wenn ich im
spiegel lesen kann
auch marlies von rechts nach links und e
center bin ich komme ja goldketten
werden schon toll ist ja weil jetzt
schon mit santa baby herumlaufen
wir glauben drauf hast du mal was gut
ist
ja also ich find die farbe halt echt
nicht meins wäre schön gewesen wenn die
farbe keine ahnung was gewesen wäre oder
so ich muss mein tragen ist 19 und mein
gott mein unser kalender kommt gleich in
die zwanziger bringe
also hier unten dass der andere der so
kaputt gegangen in dem kalender aber was
sagen wir dazu also geben mir ganz stark
new yorker vibes das lasse ich jetzt mal
so stehen also wenn sie euch gefallen
ich greife euch nicht persönlich ich
sage nur für mich es ist ja hier die
vanessa schon okay aber wir sind jetzt
in den 20ern angekommen und da erwartet
uns ist noch so wir müssen uns jetzt
wieder vorbereiten vier tage bis
weihnachten 5 jetzt freuen wir uns ganz
toll über wir ja
jetzt haben wir ein set jetzt kann man
die gleiche kette mit dem gleichen sacs
richtet sich schon an jüngere leute oder
niesen wie belgien schon ich hab da so
keine richtige meinung zu
21 na klar ein kleiner kleiner klar
wollen sie das set noch voll machen hier
haben wir noch mal die tollen sterne die
wirklich server klasse aussehen und so
ein stern motiv weißt du das haben sich
die leute schon heute wieder warum ist
auch nicht als kette mit hasen den
ohrring tragen das sieht schon so
richtig
kaugummiautomat aus ich weiß auch nicht
warum ich das denken ja sein dass das
gerade wieder mode ist aber nicht
spricht nicht am
22 das spricht ja doch bändchen ok in
der 22 befindet sich ein armbändchen aus
gold mit bekannten so ein bisschen qvc
machen kennt ihr die kuh fort also die
kennt wahrscheinlich die sendung nicht
mehr dass ich keine anschaut aber schaue
mir immer ganz gerne zum einschlafen qvc
an um frauen dabei zuzuschauen und
männern wie sie so an schmucken spielen
aber dann immer so ein bisschen die
person auch streicheln oder eincremen
weil sonnencreme beworben wird und ganz
besonders an dieser schmuck rumspielen
das hat für mich als mehr weiß ja und
jetzt mond ran und neutrale um das thema
drückte konnte das sieht ein bisschen
hochwertiger als das andere wir sind bei
petri weiß wenn ich hier noch mehr
anwender daran mache es ist schon wieder
fast vorbei das vorletzte tyche nummer
23 überzeugt ja doch könnt ihr jetzt
schon erkennen es ist ein bisschen
durcheinander
doch das ist ein tolles design dass sie
doch nicht aus es gibt so einen noch ein
bisschen mehr aus die vielleicht gerade
auf dass meine ohren gar nicht mehr
wehtun vertraglich schmuck wieder ich
hätte schwören können dass meine ohren
ganz rot naja das linke ein bisschen
aber das ist nicht wahr dass linke ist
ein bisschen warm kann sich diese um
ich versuche einfach mal hier sind so
ein komplett goldenen überzogen macht
das vielleicht den unterschied weil an
dem hier so wirklich dieses metall da wo
das ins ohr rein kommt ja wir werden
sehen
angebot habe und nun meine damen und
herren der 24 dezember es ist
weihnachten beziehungsweise heiligabend
man geht zu seinem adventskalender und
denkt sich ich habe heute am noch gar
kein sprung aber da haben die mich
bestimmt gut ausgestattet hier ist noch
mal ein kleines kärtchen fröhliche
weihnachten jetzt ist die zeit des
wartens vorbei es gerne den qr-code und
gewinne ein exklusives foto shooting mit
fotograf andreas ortner bekannt aus ich
denke mal der bildern auch dass ich mich
nackt ausziehen weil das ist doch ganz
normal beim
geschäfte oder schick aber warum hat es
ist so eine hartz iv
schwierig habe mich gerade gewundert
warum der mond also an der seite ist
obwohl die kette so gehört oder so aber
nein es ist eine halb halb kette ist
ganz toll wenn sie den nun zum beispiel
nicht dran gemacht hätten der das doch
gewesen dann hätte man sich entscheiden
können trage ich heute so komische
perlen oder trage ich eine goldene kette
man hat ein problem bei ketten dass sie
manchmal so verrutschen und so sieht die
kette aus als ob sie dauerhaft
verrutscht ist
konsum lieben konsum jetzt ist natürlich
die große frage wie schmeckt und hat es
sich gelohnt was kosten denn so ohrringe
von sixx aber da sind die bächen und
dann haben wir noch diese grün dinger
und noch andere kosten 6
99 g 8 ich habe lange keinen schmuck
gekauft ich meine das kostet ja auch
nicht dann hat das hier so ein euro war
okay ich würd sagen durchschnittswert
sind wir bei 6 euro es ist wahr wir
machen das so 69 eur 99 geteilt durch 24
ist gleich zwei euro 90 pro tag doch das
ist es manche sachen kosten ja fünf euro
dann kostet eine andere sache mit
haargummi vielleicht nur 1 euro oder
sogar euro pro türchen und dann bekommt
man so viel schmuck da brauchen wir
nicht drüber reden ob das sich lohnt
oder nicht aber jetzt kommt sie auch so
ein bisschen drauf an da haben wir mal
ich hätte ihn jetzt selber gekauft und
was gefällt mir wirklich was werde ich
behalten 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
18 19 25 21
22 das ist hier mit 24
aber da fehlt ja immer noch eine sache
hering fans und das zeug würde ich
tragen würde ich genutzt und das sind 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
13 14 15 sachen und 9
würde ich nicht halt 69 99 durch 15 ok
und das macht die nummer auf 4 eur 66
pro schmuckstücke dann lohnt es sich
immer noch kann ich ganz heraus erkennen
an wen das so gerichtet ist also was die
zielgruppe weil einerseits sehen die
sache sehr jung aus und andererseits hat
ja aktuell und modern am besten ist der
glaube ich geeignet für jemanden wo man
weil sie hat noch kein schmuck ab 13 12
vielleicht sogar schon die wird sich
darüber freuen für die ältere kategorie
gibt es ja andere schmuck
adventskalender und ich glaube da ist
man besser bedient das ist mein fazit
und damit fast das mit dem ersten video
dadurch dass es aber nicht also ich
verlose ganz viel und jetzt fragt ihr
euch aber vanessa verlust du das denn
das kommt am ende wenn wir alle ganz
kalender ausgepackt haben erfüllen wir
die adventskalender neu und ihr habt die
möglichkeit so einen adventskalender zu
gewinnen dafür müsst ihr mir auf
instagram folgen dann seht ihr wenn die
verlosung los geht und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß wie glück im leben und
abonniert diesen kanal gibt dem video
daumen nach oben um die videos zu pushen